someone on our staff spotted this  someone who works for us was watching  jeopardy recently and they spotted a  reference to our show and you know I  thought was pretty cool so check it out  my CTV 1000 Kimmy Vivino leads the  basic-cable band on this talk show with  a one-word title  Cathy what is castle no yeah what is the  - no Artie was my previous girlfriend no  you know Chicago Fire no it's the first  time they've given people multiple  choice a whole history of charity last  segment was 45 minutes long I'm also  shocked that this isn't the chew yeah  that's in here for years thinking I was  on the chew yeah you [ __ ] you don't you  [Applause]  it's like the view except it's about  fighting so they call it the shoe  you  you